on this monday night sacking single-use
plastics
canada's new timeline to ban the
manufacturing and importing of these
eco-unfriendly items we're going to see
some significant changes related to
packaging top tax to swallow i'm not
going to keep on it if it's like a
fortune the bitter reaction to one
province's new charge on some sweet
beverages
uncharted waters new rules for
transgender athletes and elite women
swimming races and no more gnome sweet
gnome that is sad a fond farewell to a
heartwarming and whimsical village
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight mithu garcia
good evening and thanks for joining us
the days are numbered for single-use
plastic in canada in just a few months
ottawa will ban making and importing
things like plastic bags and straws it
was supposed to happen last year but
like with everything else the pandemic
threw a wrench into that eric sorensen
on the fed's pollution solution and the
challenges for retailers and restaurants
at a time when we should know better
many canadians have been using more
single-use plastics all brought about by
an explosion and delivery services
during the pandemic but ottawa is now
shifting back to the environment and
starting the countdown to ban
manufacturing some plastic products by
december this year the sale of them by
december next year and to end exports in
three years these products won't be
manufactured anymore in canada therefore
you won't be able to to
to get a hold of them the ban will
affect highly visible items in our lives
plastic bags take out containers straws
cutlery stir sticks even the plastic
rings used on six packs this decision is
supported by science
it will keep our environment clean and
wildlife healthy canadians throw away
more than 3 million tons of plastic
every year less than 10 percent gets
recycled yet it's taken 70 years of
dumping plastics into the environment
for the public to gradually realize the
harm from plastics that can take decades
to decompose we're all disgusted by what
we see on our local beach so the steps
we're taking now
uh are important steps but like it's
that's the kind of time frame that we're
working on here like we're not going to
solve this problem overnight but solving
the problem is beginning some fast food
outlets have replaced plastic straws
with paper ones
retailers like sobes have eliminated
single-use plastic bags at the checkout
there will be costs to change and
industries that normally compete will
have to work together
more and more
you're seeing
companies working with other companies
to develop eco-friendly solutions in
years to come we're going to see some
significant changes related to packaging
ottawa doesn't rule out banning other
plastics in the future the ultimate goal
is zero plastic waste by 2030 the vision
of a circular economy in which all
plastics can be reused to bring an end
to the sickening amounts of unrecyclable
waste that we've created for years eric
sorensen global news toronto
one province's plan to push people to
make healthier choices is getting some
backlash in september newfoundland and
labrador will start charging a special
tax on sugary drinks the levy widely
known as the soda tax will raise
millions of dollars in revenue as ross
lord reports reaction is more sour than
sweet
at a time of overwhelming inflation a
government fishing for more tax revenue
on the backs of consumers is asking for
trouble that's what people at the
historic keynes grocery and deli and st
john's think of newfoundland and
labrador's upcoming tax on sugary drinks
customers say life is already too
expensive
in september the price of soft drinks
goes up
i'm not going to keep on it if it's like
a fortune to vibe with a path just like
gasoline the new tax is the first of its
kind in canada it will apply an extra 20
cents a liter to a wide range of
products including regular soft drinks
and others with added sugar like fruit
juices iced tea and lemonades along with
sweetened sports and energy drinks and
some frozen fruit punches
the owner of kane's grocery in delhi
says emerging from the pandemic slowdown
was already difficult with staffing
shortages and customers hard pressed to
find spending money low income are
primarily the ones they say that buy
this stuff and they're going to be hit
again in small businesses like myself
how much more do we have to incur
before the government realized that you
know we're taxed enough as it is the
government says the new tax is about
encouraging better behavior and from a
public health standpoint it's receiving
much more positive reviews we support
the government in prioritizing the
health of its citizens
and hope that other jurisdictions take
notice and follow suit british columbia
took action last year not with a new tax
but rather by removing a provincial
sales tax exemption for carbonated
beverages that contain sugar diabetes
canada says sugar taxes could help
reverse a continuing rise in the disease
almost 12 million canadians either have
diabetes or are at risk of developing it
restricting their lives and putting ever
more stress on overloaded health care
systems newfoundland and labrador's
diabetes rate is especially high
something the province's doctor turned
premier andrew fury is eager to fix
but critics insist the timing is wrong
now is not the time for the liberal
government to take more money out of
people's pockets it's the time to put
money back in people's pockets so i
asked the minister will you postpone the
sugar tax the government refuses to back
off there is choice when you when you
choose to drink a beverage you can drink
one with that's laden with sugar or you
can drink one without sugar evidence in
parts of the world that already tax
sugary drinks like france and hungary
suggest they don't always have the
desired effect that many people just get
their sugar fix somewhere else
another complication in one province's
effort to be a public health leader
ross lord global news st johns
a commission of inquiry has decided to
release videos of the police takedown of
the man who killed 22 people in nova
scotia in april of 2020 after the media
challenged the math casualty
commission's original decision not to
post the videos publicly and a warning
the images in this story are disturbing
these video images of the rcmp takedown
of the man who killed 22 people over a
13-hour rampage in several nova scotia
communities have never been seen
publicly until now the videos show the
killer pulling into the irving big stop
gas station in enfield driving a car he
stole from his final victim gina goulet
a member of an rcmp emergency response
team recognized the killer from photos
that had been shared that morning the
officer and his partner both opened fire
shooting multiple times ending the man's
life
evidence released prior at the public
inquiry showed at almost the same time
the gunman shot himself in the head the
mass casualty commission originally
decided not to release the videos
fearing they could be misused on the
internet the commission has now reversed
its decision in part because no parties
objected to their release
western leaders are warning the war in
ukraine could drag on for years that
dire message coming independently from
both u.k prime minister boris johnson
and the nato secretary general over the
weekend
russian forces are continuing to
encircle the key city of severo donetsk
in the eastern donbass region while in
the country's south ukrainian troops
have launched a major counter-offensive
around the hersen region all the while
the russians continue their
indiscriminate shelling and cruise
missile attacks on homes and other
civilian targets
the war in ukraine is amplifying the
need to modernize continental defense
today the federal government announced
it will spend nearly five billion
dollars over the next six years to
overhaul and modernize norad mercedes
stephenson explains
the brave new world of crews and
hypersonic missiles
being produced at blinding speed by
increasingly aggressive adversaries like
china and russia
rapidly outpacing north america and
norad defenses today
we turn another page
and begin norad's next chapter canada is
announcing 4.9 billion dollars over six
years to modernize continental defense
to detect threats earlier and buy more
time to react one of the biggest
projects scrapping the dated north
warning system a chain of radar stations
across the far north and replacing it
with new systems that can see over the
horizon there's also money for
satellites cloud computing
infrastructure upgrades and advanced
air-to-air missiles whether canada is
considering getting involved in the next
generation of missile defense though was
unclear what we're looking at now and
and what our allies have looked at is
what's called iamd or integrated air and
missile defense there's no doubt the
money is a big chunk of change but it
was light on details the liberal
government couldn't answer when the
money would flow or provide a breakdown
of how it would be spent and the
minister initially said the money was
new but her office later told global
news that was incorrect and the money
was already included in april's federal
budget it's a start and we're still way
behind when we think that out of all the
nato countries we're by far the farthest
behind in all of this while the details
are hazy norad's deputy commander told
global news that his american
counterparts still welcomed the money he
indicated how pleased he was to see
canada investing into norad and
continental defense so that's a very
positive step
the norad spending announced at cfb
trenton still won't get canada to the
nato benchmark of 2 percent of gdp spent
on defense something the united states
and nato have been pressuring canada to
achieve nithu
mercedes stevenson thanks
toronto hosting meetings today between
canadian finance minister and deputy pm
christian freeland and u.s treasury
secretary janet yellen as abigail beeman
reports the agenda included everything
from inflation the supply chain and
russia's war in ukraine
we detoxified it as we designed it the
american and canadian finance ministers
tour a biotech company working on
replacing petroleum with plants new
ideas for a new chapter christopher
freeland highlighting a geopolitical era
that began with the fall of the berlin
wall and that era came to an end on
february 24th
when putin invaded ukraine the two
leaders looking at supply chain
challenges made worse by the war in
ukraine in its place we've entered a
period of friendshiring friendshoring a
concept explored by the americans is
about sticking to trusted allies on
trade we saw during the pandemic that
our supply chains were very brittle and
really lacking in resilience from supply
to demand the finance minister must be
wearing industrial grade noise
cancelling earphones to avoid hearing
the calls from economist to cut her
government's over-the-top spending she
knows that it's only adding gas to the
inflationary fire scotiabank's chief
economist is the latest to say
freeland's reannouncement of budgetary
promises meant to curb inflation may not
help by giving people money whether it's
to help adjust inflation or otherwise
you're continuing to fuel that fire
suggesting a cut to government funds
instead to help cut demand we think the
bank canada could benefit from a little
help in terms of seeing that g that
government consumption
perhaps increased less than is currently
planned
just to help
take a little bit of the investment
burden off the private sector with the
u.s weighing similar options president
biden would be
supportive
of some complementary fiscal actions
that would supplement and support what
the fed is doing the bank of canada's
next announcement is in three weeks with
many expecting a 75 basis point interest
rate hike and our next look at inflation
comes this wednesday when statistics
canada releases the figures for may
abigail beeman global news ottawa
some kovit 19 vaccine travel
requirements are being dropped starting
today travelers no longer have to be
fully vaccinated in order to board a
plane or train in canada this includes
all domestic and outbound international
flights but masks must still be worn on
planes and trains cruise ship passengers
still have to be fully vaccinated and
vaccination requirements to enter canada
are still in place
from the rink to the hot seat coming up
hockey canada gets grilled about how
sexual assault lawsuits were settled
the federal court of canada has approved
a class action lawsuit against the
federal government on behalf of
off-reserve indigenous children caught
up in the so-called millennium scoop the
suit alleges the federal government
demonstrated systemic negligence in its
treatment of children who were taken
from their families and placed in
non-indigenous care the action seeks
damages on behalf of the affected
children and families and follows an
agreement in principle reached by the
federal government last year to pay 40
billion dollars to on reserve youth and
their families none of the claims have
been proven in court
executives from hockey canada playing
defense at a hearing on parliament hill
the standing committee on canadian
heritage is probing how hockey canada
dealt with sexual assault allegations
against members of the
2017-18 national junior team and if any
public money was used to pay a
settlement to the alleged victim mike
trolley reports had conversations it's
not the parliament hill penalty box but
hockey canada executives were certainly
on the hot seat this is important
testimony these are horrific allegations
and canadians
want answers at issue were public funds
used to settle a 3.55 million dollar
sexual assault lawsuit hockey canada
says no hockey canada is aware of
reports suggesting that we failed to
invest investigate this incident
attempted to cover it up and generally
swept this matter under the rug
nothing could be further from the truth
the lawsuit stems from an alleged sexual
assault in 2018 when a now 24 year old
woman accused eight canadian hockey
league players including some members of
the national junior team of assaulting
her in a london ontario hotel room as
first reported by tsn the woman claimed
the defendants directed her to say she
was sober while being video recorded and
directed her to shower after the
assaults occurred
no criminal charges were ever filed and
the woman chose not to speak with police
or with hockey canada there has to be a
mechanism
created by hockey canada that that
creates
opportunities for people to come forward
it that in itself is
sensitive and complicated
as i understand it there are people in
hockey canada
who are highly embarrassed by this and
are working to do that
but um
it's not a a one-step solution mp karen
vecchio wants action now because she
sees this case as a national
embarrassment we've allowed this to
happen too we've created this we've
created this culture that we allow this
i look at our hockey players as our
hollywood of canada right that's they
are our movie stars here and
they make mistakes too but we've got to
change that culture and we've got to let
them know what's right from wrong hockey
canada acknowledges they have a problem
and say they're on a journey to change
the sport for the better mike really
global news toronto
ahead the global and controversial new
policy seeking the hopes of
transgendered swimmers
fina the world governing body for
aquatic sports has adopted what's being
called a gender inclusion policy which
would prevent many trans women from
competing in female events the new rules
come as a response to the controversy
surrounding the winning performances of
u.s college swimmer leah thomas earlier
this year and as redmond shannon reports
there is unlikely to be any solution
which is seen as totally fair
when u.s swimmer leah thomas won a
national college title this year it was
seen by some as a beacon of inclusion
but by others as deeply unfair the trans
woman has said she wants to compete in
the olympics thank you
my dear friends
but under new rules adopted by fina the
organization governing international
swimming that will not be possible it is
a policy that we need to introduce in
order to protect the competitive
fairness
of our of our event fina says that
anyone born male who wants to compete as
a woman must exhibit low or suppressed
levels of testosterone a rule already in
place in many sports but in addition the
athletes must have transitioned before
the onset of puberty or the age of 12
whichever is later the only other sport
to add the puberty rule has been rugby
professor ross tucker consulted on that
implementation most of the biology that
differs between males and females
is very minimally affected when you
lower the testosterone they're not
worried about testosterone they're
worried about has that person
had male biological puberty and have
they had the benefits
swimming canada's ceo says he welcomes
the clarity of the rules but his
organization will only implement them in
races where canadian athletes could
qualify for international events its
domestic policy still allows athletes to
register under the gender of their
choice fina also says it aims to add an
open category for trans athletes
although it hasn't said when and how
that would work that's not inclusive
that doesn't include them because it
others trans people when
you know trans women or women and trans
men are men
canadian lgbtq plus rights groups have
called the new rules draconian
discriminatory and unscientific redmond
shannon global news london
a japanese court has dealt a major
setback to lgbtq rights the court in
osaka ruled the country's ban on
same-sex marriage is not
unconstitutional under the current rules
japan is the only g7 country that hasn't
granted same-sex couples the right to
legally marry the ruling comes as
opinion polls show the majority of the
japanese public supports legalizing
same-sex marriage
neighborhood gnomes next the magical
locals who stole the hearts of a toronto
community
a toronto neighborhood is saying goodbye
to some tiny residents who are now a big
part of their hearts after they helped
everyone get through the pandemic
together for years they've had the
pleasant company of magical gnomes
living on one resident's front yard
sadly as morgan campbell explains the
gnomes are now packing their bags
it is a tiny gnome village that has had
a huge impact on this toronto community
igniting the imaginations
of many i picture like little screaming
kids
just like
millions of little screaming gnomes
there and
when they're outside they're getting
relief started just prior to the
pandemic the miniature village was built
by kathy nichols and her husband it all
started with this red fairy door and
quickly grew to include gnomes of all
shapes and sizes not to mention other
teensy friends as well i think they do
have their own little lives and you know
i'm just their caretaker it is a little
known fact that these little statues
symbolize good luck and are the
nocturnal protectors of the earth i love
seeing it every day and i love seeing
the little kids stop but there is now a
sold sign on the village it matches the
one on their caretaker's home as the
nichols family prepares for their next
chapter but what will happen to the
gnomes it is not likely they would
qualify for a gnome equity loan i'm
moving to lindsay lindsay needs a gnome
home my neighbor down the street has
recently just got her own gnome door
fairy door and she's going to now take
up the practice but not without some
tears shed they're going on to their
next
chapter but i'm like it's just yeah it
is sad the nichols family hopes the
story of their gnomes will inspire
others i'm not the only one that loves
the whole idea of a little gnome village
so let's go and spread the love morgan
campbell global news toronto
and that is global national for this
monday night i'm nitu garcia tonight's
your canada is near courtney british
columbia thanks for watching i'll see
you here again tomorrow have a great
night
[Music]
you